the tone of the movie is an important
thing for the editor to carry and you
brought a lot of you have a comedy
background and you brought a lot of that
to this film can you talk to me about
the choices you had to make I assume
there were many many choices to make in
anything involving Jeff Goldblum yes
almost too many but still I'm coming
from a world where you know guys keep
the camera running for 45 minutes and so
I've got excuse me
hours and hours of footage so this was
lighter than that but the Cullum stuff
would be the exception for any given
scene we probably had 20 30 different
ways to cut it honestly
oh yeah I think on the on the blu-ray I
suggest we have like a 5 disc box set
totally gold standard extended go blooms
like that cuz here's this scene for diff
he's amazing you guys thought that stuff
food we we had this great like bit we
were like okay says no just talk about
camping and intense is that he's great
tents camping camping why would you go
camping and tents are just clothes but
there's a lot more space between your
body and the outer layer so very true
we're all camping we're all wearing
tents just some of us choose to wear out
our tents closer to our bodies there's
an amazing fit year that there's amazing
that went on and on five minutes and
like that bit ways he melts the cousin
and is great laughs five minutes before
he melts the cousin trying to I figure
it's gambling there's a crime on it's a
car called scambling it's gambling well
scambling
no no we all know about scam play I used
to be a big scam blur back in there 70
sec well I believe we did not found out
find out what a scam bling was actually
but that's why he got melted so market
would I talk about the music and I felt
like while I was watching it that I was
getting a little bit of a not just like
the Flash Gordon 80s vibe but the like
is almost like a 8-bit video game
musical theme there and can you talk to
me about the inspirations that you chose
I think you're the perfect guy for this
gives your roots are in Devo and in
synth pop and electronica so how did you
combine all of those elements for the
themes to Thor the first thing that
Tychus said to me when we were talking
about music for the film he described
the film is a road trip between Thor and
Hulk and I just imagined like them in a
Cadillac convertible driving across
Arizona like a Thelma and Louise kind of
thing you know but the Marvel version of
it you're living in it as good and then
he sent me New Zealand
awesome like not on the map synth bands
and and michelle's are things like that
and Gallipoli Gallipoli is one of the
greatest films because of Jean show John
and that's kind of where it started out
with him and in the meantime Marvel
wanted to know if I was comfortable with
a big orchestra and so you know I knew
that there were multiple elements that
were gonna be involved so each of you
can you walk me through your personal
favorite thing your detail in the movie
or something that the audience may not
even pick up on the first go around but
just something that you're very proud of
doesn't have to be from a main character
we'll start with - well I built the
many many costumes and Tai Chi was
always there the costume department
personally to try every costume no
matter if he was Asgardian ladies
sectarian ladies or guards whatever no
if it did I think he had to try the
grandmasters costumes first he's like no
matter what time I'm gonna finish
shooting I have to try it so he will be
that was amazing
he just really genuinely wanted to feel
I think what the actor is gonna feel by
wearing that costume so the process was
amazing because he was always there next
to us you know directing us and giving
us the opinion of these it was fantastic
how about you Eric your favorite moment
from working in this film my favorite
moment is Luke Hemsworth as actor Thor
screaming no it always makes me laugh it
always made me laugh every scream of
know every take I thought it was so
funny it's just I just think it's the
best of a doozy I like the port where
Thor's in the gladiator kind of training
area and it's talking to Val and goes on
that rant about you know the women it's
about time women have their own army
love that I'm so so so glad we got to
keep that mark is their favorite cue or
piece of music from the film well um I
kind of liked all things on planet
Sarkar just because it gave me a chance
to kind of inject electronics into it
you know along with a hundred piece
Orchestra that's playing through the
majority of the film but also that's the
section where I could put in subliminal
messages so
tell us you listen you'll you'll find
him there in there well what are we
listening for it by Pepsi tell us some
of the subliminal messages what else
have you got
you just have to listen all right my
many favourite moments one of my
all-time favorites is Thor's story about
Loki trying to kill him when he was a
kid because I remember on set and we
should have been fired at that point but
yeah okay so do this thing but just talk
about yeah when Loki like tried to kill
you as a kid in tellus and we did maybe
like eight or nine versions of their
thing different stories in his Barney's
up when one day I was walking on a field
and I saw a I saw a Turkish rug on the
field and you know I love Turkish rugs
so I understand on the Turkish rug but I
was hovering over a over a hole and it
was located from a Turkish rug becca
delucci said haha it's a hole and he
dropped dead I drop down I was impaled
on some spikes and it was just it's just
so many different versions that thing
and there's one of my most favorite days
just coming up with this these stupid
stories that should never have been in
the film thank you guys so much for
coming to the screening thank you for
sticking around